NUNES AND KACH PATEL, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Brian: COMING UP NOW KARL
ROVE FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF FOR
GEORGE W. BUSH AND VERY SMART
GRIND KATIE PAVLICH TOWN HALL
NEWS.COM NEWS EDITOR AND BOTH
ARE FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTORS.
KATIE, LET'S START WITH YOU, I
THINK WE ARE BEING TESTED.
I FEEL LIKE WE ARE BEING TESTED
BY THE RUSSIANS WHO ARE PREIT
ANDING AS IF YOU DON'T HAVE
CONTROL OF HACKING GROUPS INSIDE
THEIR BORDERS, AM I WRONG.
>> WE ARE ABSOLUTELY BEING
TESTED, BRIBE, THE WHITE HOUSE
CONTINUES TO SAY THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT WAS NOT BEHIND THESE
ATTACKS.
MAYBE THEY WEREN'T BUT THEY
CERTAINLY WERE WATCHING THE
CYBERATTACK PLAY OUT AS WAS
CHINA, AS WERE OTHER ACTORS WHO
HAVE VERY SERIOUS AND SKILLED
CYBERATTACK FORCES THAT THEY
WOULD BE HAPPY TO USE AGAINST
THE UNITED STATES TO CRIPPLE THE
ECONOMY AND TO PIT AMERICANS
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
AND IT'S NOT JUST ON THE
CYBERATTACK WE ARE SEEING THIS
NOW PLAY OUT IN THE MIDDLE EAST
WHERE HAMAS AND HEZBOLLAH ARE
TESTING PRESIDENT BIDEN ON HIS
RESPONSE THERE AS HIS STATE
DEPARTMENT NEGOTIATES IN VIENNA
TO GET THE UNITED STATES BACK IN
TO THE IRANIAN NUCLEAR AGREEMENT
AND IN TERMS OF THE DOCTRINE AND
WHAT THE BIDEN DOCTRINE WILL BE
ON FOREIGN POLICY, CAN YOU LOOK
NO FURTHER THAN THE OBAMA
DOCTRINE WHEN IT CAME TO IRAN
AND THEY APPEASED THAT REGIME,
WHICH OF COURSE, IS THE LARGEST
STATE SPONSOR OF TERRORISM IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD.
ADMITTED THAT INFLUX OF CASH
THAT THEY WOULD RECEIVE AS A
RESULT OF THAT DEAL THAT WE
SIGNED UNDER OBAMA AND GOT OUT
OF UNDER TRUMP WOULD LEAD TO
MORE TERRORISM AND WENT INTO IT
ANYWAY.
SO WHEN YOU ARE SEEING THIS
BARRAGE OF ROCKETS ON AN ALLY,
WHICH IS ISRAEL, THAT'S THE
BIGGER PICTURE THERE IS THE
IRANIANS AND HOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WILL RESPOND TO
THEIR TERRORISM AND OUTSIDE OF
THE NUCLEAR AGREEMENT THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO GET BACK INTO.
>> Brian: KARL, WHEN WE OPENED
UP THE BIDEN DOCTRINE, WHAT PAGE
DO WE OPEN UP TO TO FIND OUT HIS
POLICY ON IRAN?
WE NOW KNOW THAT THAT WAS NOT A
POPULAR AGREEMENT IN 2015.
WE KNOW THAT SENATOR SCHUMER AND
CARDIN AND MENENDEZ DIDN'T SIGN
OFF ON IT HE BARELY GOT OVER 40
VOTES AND HAD THE MAJORITY IN
THE SENATE.
53 STATE DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
SIGNED A LETTER ASKING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DO A DEAL AND
SALUTED THEM FOR THE INDIRECT
TALKS IN VIENNA LED BY A LOT OF
IMPORTANT DEMOCRATS.
THEY WANT THIS DEAL DONE.
SO, WHAT IS THE BIND TO COME
TRIP?
SHOULD THEY GET IT DONE?
>> WELL, DEFINITELY NOT.
BUT, NOTICE WHO THOSE 53
SIGNATORIES ARE ON THE LETTER.
THEY'RE THE LEFT WING OF THE
LEFT WING OF THE LEFT WING OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Brian: INCLUDING KEITH KEITH
ELLISON.
COMPLETE LEFT WINGERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, HARD LEFT.
MANY OF THEM CRITICS OF ISRAEL.
SO, WHY NOT TAKE ISRAEL'S
GREATEST OPPONENT IN THE REGION
AND THE LARGEST FUNDER OF
TERRORISM IN THE REGION AND MAKE
NICE WITH THEM RATHER THAN
STANDING BY ISRAEL?
SO, NO, THIS WAS TO BE EXPECTED
AT SOME POINT, AT SOME TIME.
I THINK IT'S NOT BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS BEING STRONG
ON IRAN OR TAKING -- OR STANDING
BY THE SANCTIONS, BUT, INSTEAD,
BECAUSE IT'S NOT REALLY CLEAR
WHAT THEIR POLICY IS EXCEPT
LET'S MAKE A DEAL AND THE LEFT
WANTS TO PUSH THEM IN THE
DIRECTION OF PLAYING LET'S MAKE
A DEAL.
I WANT TO GO BACK AND SAY ONE
THING THOUGH ABOUT THE COLONIAL
PIPELINE.
I WAS SHOCKED WHEN THE PRESIDENT
WENT OUT AND WAS ASKED ABOUT
THIS FOLLOWING HIS NEWS
CONFERENCE AND RATHER THAN
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO GET THESE
GUYS AND MAYBE HE SHOULD HAVE
SAID ALSO WE ARE TALKING TO THE
RUSSIANS TO TRY AND UNDERSTAND
WHETHER THEY WERE INVOLVED IN
THIS OR NOT AND THEY BETTER NOT
BE BECAUSE THERE WILL BE A PRICE
TO BE PAID.
WHAT DID HE DO?
HE SORT OF PIVOTED AND STARTED
TALKING ABOUT HOW WE NEEDED TO
HAVE EDUCATION PROGRAMS THAT
MEANT MORE OF OUR SCHOOL
CHILDREN WOULD BE ABLE TO
GRADUATE WITH DEGREES IN CODING
AND BECOME, YOU KNOW, CYBER
WARRIORS.
AND OF COURSE THAT WILL ONLY
TAKE LIKE TEN YEARS.
WE GOT AN IMMEDIATE PROBLEM.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
MA'AMY PAMY WAY OFF IN THE
FUTURE IT WAS A VERY STRANGE
RESPONSE.
>> Katie: AND HE WALKED AWAY.
HE SAID I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
HE SAID I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS.
YOU GUYS ARE BAD DIDN'T WANT TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT IT AND
ATTEMPTED TO LEAVE.
>> Brian: I JUST WONDER, KARL,
IF YOU TOLD GEORGE W. BUSH NOT
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I WONDER
HOW THAT WOULD HAVE WENT OVER.
>> THE QUESTION WAS DON'T ANSWER
QUESTIONS FROM BRIAN KILMEADE.
THAT WAS THE ONE GOLDEN RULE.
>> Brian: AND HE WAS VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT EXCEPT FOR HE
LET ME DO THE PLAY BY PLAY ON
THE LAST T-BALL GAME AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WIT